[Music]
thank you thank you well so many people
so it's really an honor to be here I've
been waiting for this day since I sent
my applications I'm really really happy
to be here even better I'm even happier
to see so many of you here so I'm gonna
guess some of you are Pokemon freaks but
now let's start Who am I my name is one
and normally from nine to six they call
me a software engineer be ta da at level
which is a dating app in Germany however
today I would like to scratch this title
and I want to be a Pokemon data master
why is that well because into the
representation which is titled detecting
Pikachu on Android and more you see in
terms of low audio detection I'm going
to be talking about Pokemon and data so
please enjoy relax it's a really cool
presentation so enjoy so now first
question and please do not disappoint me
what is this no answers yet what is this
exactly perfect so speak as you yellow
mouth red cheeks we love it
however what about computers they do not
know what is the finishing right if I go
now to my computer and I'm like hey what
is this it's not gonna say anything
because computers do not talk so they
are pretty ignorant about Pikachu's and
this makes me unhappy because we know
what is Pikachu and computers and
devices they do not know so my goal here
with this experiment is this I want to
close this gap of ignorance I want to
finish computers what a Pikachu is but
before I start sin this is about pika so
an object detection let's take a small
example that's because you write and
that's a really nice green box meaning
that this is indeed one Pikachu so this
is my agenda for today I'm going to
divide this presentation into three main
parts first I'm going to be talking
about theory because it's always nice to
know what's going on under the hood then
also I'm going to explain you guys how I
built my own cost on detection system
for because you and then even cooler how
I am using these small
so let's turn now what is object
detection well I like to define object
detection as the process of recognizing
instances of an object in images or
video in any frame however I'm really
sure that maybe some of you may be back
there is asking hang on what is the
different between objection and image
classification and that's a really
really nice question might be a friend
and the answer is this or my own answer
so here we have two images right normal
Pikachu and the object detection let's
suppose that we have the best pocket
exit we have the best Pokemon detection
classifier classification sorry that we
fit one image and the opposite going to
the Pikachu right really straightforward
X image why Pikachu
however in object detection the goal is
more granular here we want to know
something even more than just knowing
that it's a Pikachu here I want to know
exactly where my Pikachu is located and
this is nice because maybe you have the
use case of you want to know the
relation of this object from the other
one for example if pick a shoe on top
below
besides this also maybe we want to know
how many pika shoes I have and here we
can see that we had like two different
labels because you pick a shoe indeed to
pick as just one and two perfect
however on the other image let's suppose
that we have a thousand Pikachu the
output is still going to be Pikachu
right but we would know exactly how many
Pikachu's I have so doesn't mean
different here is more granular is more
specific and here is just like yes
ossification and it's the same whether
you say and how did I build this like
how did I did my system and I use them
so Flavia detection API which is tens of
lose answer to the detection problem and
this library is really really cool and
the best part is that it is able to
treat accuracy for speed and memory
consumption meaning that we are able to
make our system a little bit more weak
in terms of accuracy however is going to
be even better instead of speed and
memory consumption meaning that we will
able to deploy it in weak devices such
as morals and why is this well this is
due to the fact that the package include
many many many official extractor sorry
and architectures and we're able to play
around with them we can choose this
architecture or we can use this
extractor and we keep playing around
with them we might able to find the
right balance between speed and accuracy
so now let's start
get some paper recommend maybe so noise
you want to take some notes and let's
talk about how I built my own detection
system first of course we need to insert
tensorflow I'm really sure that most of
you already have it but more than that
we also need to clone the repo called
models meaning that we have to go into
terms of log github you have to look for
the Rubicon models and you're going to
clone that one three four were right but
next we need to create our dataset so
simply just get a bunch of images I use
around 230 and 80% of them which is from
training and they reminders 20% were
used to ever rate and I try to be as
diverse as possible you know try using
pikachu's from the cars from the anime
from different season of the anime of
the anime fan art and so on also I try
to get different position of Pikachu but
let's be honest Pikachu sir it's a fake
yellow Mouse so every time somebody's
going to draw it it's going to focus on
a knife a perfect it's working
nope yeah perfect ok so as I was saying
every single time someone is going to
draw Pikachu is going to focus on the
main features which are the red cheeks
the tail and the ear so it was quite
hard to get other angles of my dear
Pikachu so after that we have to label
our data set and the process of labeling
here is quite different than what we are
used to why because here we are dealing
with object action so we need to tell
our system hey this is my object and the
main idea here using one of the many
software that are available for doing
this is that you are going to draw a
bounding box surrounding your Pikachu
and this takes a lot of time is really
boring to concentrate your mouth load
the image draw click and then you do
need to write the name
Pikachu so please just do some necklace
for a financial because you're going to
need it because this is really really
boring so every time you label one image
this is going to output an XML file
which is going to contain the name of
your image the name of your object and
the coordinate of your object which in
this case is these tiny box that we have
here but tensorflow
it does not deal with XML tensorflow is
like and the heck is this I don't like
xml's so we need to transform this into
a format that XML that test of loss
notes and this one is called TF record
and the wrap-up it already contains all
the code the script that you need to do
this you simply need to specify where
are your XML and this is going to output
one nice file called TF record and I
have this script also in my github I'm
going to present the link at the very
end so every time I talk about script or
code believe me it's going to be on
github so don't worry sell a lot then
there's something else that we need and
it's called the label map and the level
map is simply one really tiny file that
contains the ID of your item and the
name of your object in the sky in my ID
is number one and my object is pick a
shoe please keep in mind to know use ID
zero because that number is researched
so so far let me breathe a bit so I
talked about how to install tensorflow
and what exactly we need I talked about
how we have to create the data set how
to label the data set followed by
creating the TF record file and the
label map now let's move on to something
more interesting how do we train this
because this is the the good part so the
training here is based on one amazing
file is called let's call it the
pipeline and in the pipeline you specify
everything regarding your training now
this file it is divided into five
different sections the first one of them
is called model and in model we're going
to specify the architecture which is my
obvious detection architecture that I
would like to use we also specifies the
feature extractor and the loss function
then we have training config and in
training config we are going to write
about the number of epochs that we want
to use for our training the size of my
badge and the training
Check Point then we have the train input
reader and evaluation input reader are
here we specify where is our training
set and our evaluation set and lastly
there is evil config and here we're
going to write the number of example
that we want to use to evaluate our
model now this file here looks quite
simple but in reality is really really
complex - and made out of 180 images
however tens of wrote there's such a
nice guy so they already provided with a
huge list of example config files that
we can use so we don't have to spend
hours and they just like tweaking all
these little numbers like training
whatever I Delta alpha all this small
thing that we'll use for the renewal we
don't have to do this they already did
it for us so instead of spending hours
doing this just go there just find one
and just play around with it so now how
do we run this well there is another
script in the report is called train dot
PI and we're simply going to call this
script and we're going to use as a
parameter the path to my training
directory which is the directory where
you have the TF record and the label map
and then you also need to specify where
is your PI plan file but now before
moving on I start talking about this and
continue talking about this I wanted to
make a small stop and talk about with
architecture i am using because like I
say theories of it nice so the
architecture I use is called SSD we
stand for single detection single shot
detection and it is called single shot
detection because it's going to predict
the class of my object and its location
during the same shot the opposite of
this is an architecture that require a
second component named the proposal
generator
to predict the position of the box and
this is an image from the official paper
that described the library and here we
have three different architectures
SSD faster our CNN and our FCM and we
can see that here there's only one box
after the feature extractor because
everything is going to be performed in
one single shot all the orders - they
have like two different boxes I know
it's quite hard to grasp the concept so
if you guys are more interested in this
this is thinning of the paper is really
amazing and awesome I have a copy
somewhere so if someone was to take a
look
feel free to ask me but now let's move
on how do I ever like this I'm training
how do I know if my mother is going to
be an amazing one or a really boring and
shitty one so they already provide
another script called evaluation dog
Python and when you execute this script
this is going to calculate a lot of
different metrics regarding your model
and the one I use personally is called a
total loss because it's obvious is
always nice to see the loss and also one
use Pascal vo c m AP mean average
precision however how do we see this
it's like yeah we're calculating all of
this but we want to see them right so
some of you might know that tensorflow
has a component called tensor board
which is its web UI which can be used
for a lot of different reasons and it is
also available for this project we can
sit and support to see the performance
of the model and this is an example of
how it looks like there is like a
thousand of photons pretty graph and so
on so just feel free to play around with
it but even even better is that we can
see the process of our training right
here in tensor board meaning that we are
able to see the detections Ryder and
even cooler here the slider and this
lighter is going to move through every
single checkpoint of my training so we
can evaluate our training for example in
epoch thousand in epoch 2009 87 so and
it's really nice because when you start
from the first one normally you don't
have any boxes but you can see how the
boxes are going to like put to show up
meaning that your model and your
training is indeed working and how do we
run this really simple we run this every
valid Python and we use the same
parameter that we used before we have to
repeat so often lights run in directory
and checkpoint directory they are
normally the same one and how do we run
tests so board well we just call test or
board and then we saying as a parameter
they pass to my training directory so
now training is over is nice we are
happy with it but now what we need to
freeze this model we want to use it so
doing every single checkpoint tensorflow
is going to create three files
and they end in the extension dot data
dot index dot meta but this is a lot of
information like I don't want three
files in my pocket you know this one one
so for that we have to freeze our model
and they already provide one file called
export inference graph and when we call
this file we're going to specify which
is the number or my checkpoint that I
want to use you see what I have here
this X X X X X so we're going to write
the Sheikh point that we want to freeze
and then after this you're going to have
one file called frozen inference graph
and this my friends this is what you
want this is what you want to keep in
your USB in Google Drive drug boss or
send it to your mom this is our mother
so please take care of it
but now let me take another small break
to breathe a second going quite fast so
I'm going to slow down so so far I have
talked about how to train our system the
whole pipeline file we need air we
specify the model and so on then I talk
about the architecture I'm using SSD or
single shot detection then how do we
evaluate our model followed by these how
to freeze our model but now the cool
part how do we use this my model is
perfect I want to impress my friends I
want to impress all of you guys
so the first use case that I tried was a
really simple one images right and in
the repo there's already a Python
notebook which has most of the code that
we need for this again and the only
thing you need to change let's say your
stone really specific like where is your
frozen model what is the threshold and
confidence ratio that you would like to
use also maybe you want to change the
color of the box no we do not like green
you want it yellow but because yellow so
that's not a good decision and so on and
this is an example of how the code looks
like I'm respecting you guys to see this
really far but just to give a small idea
of what's going on here
so first of course we need to load our
image there then we need to convert our
image into an array representation using
numpy then we are going to run there
tensorflow section on this and this is
going to return three main things the
one is the box if there's one box what
is the coordinate on my detection box
followed by 8 we have desc
what is there my confidence call house
sure I am that this is indeed one
Pikachu and not one yellow blob also the
glass what is my class if speaker she or
is it zero is no lease nothing then we
call this function call visualize boxes
and label on image array using this
parameter and this is the result
detection bosses unpick ashes here we
can see five different Pikachu's we can
see that the one in the middle is a
foster negative because indeed that's a
bit casual but like I mentioned earlier
I couldn't find so many images of we're
angles of Pikachu and in such cases it's
not going to get detected but we can see
in this case and we like this one
because we see Pikachu with two pigeons
and I've seen the prediction in my
opinion is really clean because the box
is trying what it should be is not
getting so much of the P issue and the
the worst case is Center who have been a
detection of the whole image and here we
can see because should sleep in because
you happy and teenage Pikachu so now on
Android so how do we do this on Android
so first of course we need to get the
Android demo pro unit from terms of flow
so please now we need to clone the
tensorflow repo not the modest one they
want from the official tends to flow one
and somewhere there's other I took other
I directory called Android this is what
we need
also we're going to need Android studio
so get ready to install another IDE
Ranger computer so now we need to import
the project so we're going to under
studio important to create and we're
going to select the directory I
mentioned 27 seconds ago this one
country remember and here in overall our
goal is going to be to install the demo
app however however there's once well
like as some changes that we want to do
to the actual Java code we want to
specify words our model once again and
then maybe we want to change the the
confident threshold so we need to play
around with it a tiny bit also we need
to build and compile our project under
three sort of you know about Android but
normally do to this using Gradle they
already provide the grade of fact you
only need to click the green
hammer bottle and is going to beef
however by default at least one I did it
there is one variable called native
build system and by default it is set to
none if you keep it by known the project
is going to run but you won't get the
dependency so maybe your own app your
app is going to crash so please make
sure that you use all any of the other
options that already provide forbidding
the project which are they still make
file or see make and then everything is
ready we build the project let's make
the magic happens so we go into this
really cool bar we played a we click the
green play button and if we are lucky
our place by the way make sure your
device is connected really important and
if we are lucky we are going to have a
nice up join however I was not that
lucky
Danton Tom three seconds of silence
errors errors errors angry faces and you
have no idea how many bad words I said
this my dear friends this six ways of
looking at this and as far as I could
understood what really what this mean of
this blah blah blah blah blah is that
there is one operation or one node in my
frozen model that is not available on
the Android side what I was like what so
I tried a lot of things first of course
I make sure that is the same version
even the same Committee version full on
my project and didn't work I went to
github I did an issue nothing a lot of
people commented you're the same no
solution so overflowed the same six
weeks I was like Jesus Christ it was
almost like Christmas I was home
drinking pina coladas and just thinking
about Pikachu's and this and it was
really frustrating I was about just like
to throw everything away and that's it
but then one day one day after the pina
colada I went home I went to that cold
and I took a look at the file the script
I used for freezing the model because to
be honest since they already provide the
file the script
you don't have to write anything so you
just run it under seed and deep inside
you know like so deep inside the code
there is one function I had Tony
remember the name and he has this
variable it's called optimize graph
and by default is set to true and I was
like I don't want to optimize anything
you know I was really angry that there
was I do not want to optimize
I want the model wrong the way it should
be the way terms of love didi row
without optimization so I just going to
the varible I put my mouse in the words
room I did bucks pay back stay back stay
back Spain four times because through is
four letters and then I wrote a half a
LSE false then I've lost my model I took
it again I went to Android and guess
what happened it works today actually
have no clue what that happened I'm not
smart enough to know exactly why but
please do not optimize your model okay
because it's not gonna work on Android
and they say how it looks look how
beautiful it looks
this is my app this is a Pokemon car I
have here on the back of my phone it's
my example photo it's impressing my
friends and we come to that detection is
quite cool here we have another
screenshot and we have five detection at
the same time this one it wasn't
detected but come on I got like five out
of six I think it's nice so it works
it's nice but however let's be honest
I'll be really honest with you because I
like you guys I was not so happy you
know I was not so happy I was like high
school but I feel like it could be
better you know I feel like the Android
side was kind of weak there was a lot of
false positive because you know detect
that it was really slow so I I was
expecting something more I was not proud
of myself so what I decided to improve a
tiny beat my pro yet so I had a seventy
more images this time I really tried to
get more sight images of Pikachu
then I extended my training for another
5,000 a Potts and lastly this like I'm
fix ashamed the detection threshold on
the Android app 2.85 and it was it it
was very was better so now I have a new
model and I want to try it with
something new I was like oh god spoilers
only I wanted to do something new and
the next use case was like guess what
videos and it was like you know I want
to do this on videos also the western of
the recommendation that song
some people gave me after the first time
I do did you play a Pokemon episode of
and get all the food caches and I was
like I think I'll do it so I did it
now this is once again an example of the
code is really similar to the previous
one however I would like to point out
two main difference first is that
instead of loading one image full we
have to load their video of course then
we have to eat array through every
single frame of my video and we're going
to capture that frame and then we're
going to treat this frame as my image
then taking this frame we're going to
get all the detection and this is going
to return a copy of the frame but with
the detection now I have one object here
called be the writer and in this pedo
writer you are going to fill it with all
these new frames so it's going to create
a new video based on your friends with
the detection and get some popcorn
because I'm going to show you an example
is only one minute long so enjoy because
you live ketchup there we go
oops something wrong what is happened no
Pikachu detected that's awful all guy
talking
oops because she's bought detected
classic pig there we go that's nice oh
come on no detection that's sad
nothing is perfect ash talking uh-huh
miss is angry like always I'm broke is
just been brought
but then Ton Ton Ton oh there we go
because you how's the ketchup body fiber
want some ketchup oh my god can she was
broken whoops
mistakes and now because she's sad
because he has no ketchup bottle so
sorry buddy so now results
thank you no results so in overall the
main issue here is the number of false
positive are we saw in the video site
there was the text it's like come on
site is green what's going on tensorflow
so for me that was like a big letdown
also once again is that the Android are
still it feels better but I still feel
like I could do a little bit more work
so you know we're all if I compare the
Android with the other two they're quite
weak I'm gonna show you an example there
when doing the question so you guys can
play around if you want but now
conclusion in overall I'm quite happy
and pleased with the result I mean I
have my own Pikachu detection system
even on my phone and it is enough to
impress but is here your friends I'm
going to Pokemon freaks and maybe your
mom you're carrying on all of you guys
also you know it's been quite nice and
interesting to play around this feel of
deep learning just something different
and also I'm here speaking to all of you
today which is quite cool so for the
future I would like to keep improving my
training set maybe to use more images or
like non frontal images of Pikachu maybe
try another configuration of my future
destructor an architecture because the
one I use is like the weakest one
because I this time I want a better
performance instead of memory and speed
because I really really wanted to have
it on my phone and I'm sure that if I
try some of the most complex architects
you are going to get a better result but
maybe I won't be able to run it on my
phone and also I would like to add a
second class just to make it more
interesting so maybe Charmander
so that's it like thank for your time
here I have all my info I have my medium
blog just in case you guys would like to
know more there I have like two articles
describing these with every single
detail so feel free to read at it you
have any question please ask me a lot of
people have wrote me like hey man my
mother is not working people that are
having the same issue the thing I say
with Android and I tell them the same do
not optimize your model so it's quite
nice really
and yeah I've seen the C credit to the
son of the icons I use and thank you
[Applause]
so there's plenty of time for some
questions but I'm gonna steal the first
one so effectively you you are now
building a pokedex kinda okay yeah I
just out of curiosity because the the
model for just Pikachu how big is that
how big really really small is I think
it's around 20 megabytes I have it
somewhere bodies I have it all on github
and I gotta get home it does not allow
such a big files first really tiny but
if you would like actually try to make
the pokey the extra for the first 150
poke if it's going to grow that if I
can't really answer that right now I'll
have to after right Billy with
Charmander then I send you an email like
hey this is now the size of the model so
I am assuming is going to grow but I
thought I can't really tell you by how
much it's going to grow fair enough
let's have all the pokemon with
questions yeah meanwhile I'm going to
set the visor here you wanna do a demo
not on me but while you guys ask I just
want to have this running here quickly
oh yeah feel free to ask me thanks for
all the Pikachu's asked about Charmander
but your sensor that thank you did your
training sets also contain photos of
nothing like no Pikachu's or did you
know like all of them were Pikachu yeah
to be honest I just wanted to make it
run sorry I'm just like focusing okay
this is and because you I could have
tried just like to have images with no
label to see if the model performs
better but I was just focusing like Nana
just you speak as you want does it how
often is your model matches righteous or
[ __ ] okay
righteous I have never seen a right you
but I have here an example with Pichu if
my app starts to work so I can actually
show it to you but it's actually like
with specious it happens sometimes
because maybe like the color palette is
quite similar to this thing especially
the same color but right you oh my god
is so nerd but as I show is more like
orange II so maybe does not detect it
yeah
I mean we try to it had never happened
but especially tapas like all the time I
have here the feature to show you both
as always the demo is not working now we
have five minutes so we can wait okay
well question I suppose I have have you
tried just putting a picture of a yellow
blob yeah I have it here but indeed it
does not get detected but come on okay
any other questions
yeah just feel free to ask like there's
another question well I've thrower here
with my how is the practicality of
having models like that on Android
phones because it seems I'm an Android
dev huh and it seems it laughs it loads
a lot of battery memory RAM for instance
an app is usually about 50 megabytes it
shouldn't be more than that the rice
paper starts uninstalling them so how
far are we to having actually tensorflow
as something that can actually be
included in and yet so I seem that want
to really answer that question as you
have to train with the other
architectures because like I said I used
the weakest one and it was okay I don't
have any issues but I really would like
to try the other ones so I can make the
difference
from my own experience I can tell you
that if not like my phone gets hot or
anything nah me it's also like a pixel
too so it's quite fine however like is I
don't see any really bad improving on
the battery or the phone getting slow
like it works the way it should be but I
cannot do that on purpose like I wanted
to use the weakest architecture so I
have to try it with the most intense
architecture one thing I asked in like I
will able to other thought that question
anyone else I think everyone's really
keen on seeing a demo
yes it's Ella it is connected right oh
there's a question
oh there it is what I'm going to get now
one ad because this is my phone
hopefully I won't get any weird Jesus
Lord who demo time
yeah see anything there's a flow detect
so Pikachu right phone camera and now
since not everything is positive in life
then false positive because you boo it's
not Pikachu is pitch you and here I'll
come on man really if it's a bit slow
like I say it so we need some time oh
[Music]
boy
fail but this one is better yeah more
Pikachu
hey so sweet it's fun it's nice to have
some laughs and to today wrong with it
so we have to give him like one round of
applause just for that anyone oh there
is one more question and after that we
will switch thank you uh thank you for
talking about you talking about models
and models different structures and use
the tensorflow
but we what are you that greece model
that you use in the tenth flow as deep
learning or just traditional I know that
question was coming so I have fun
appendix here so GDP which my mouth my
mouth my mouth yeah really
so the future destructor we are actually
like continent the vehicle convolution
of feature extractor and they want to
use coal more wine net and it's
basically just a neural network which is
going to get the features of your object
and here this is like a a screenshot
from the actual
if occasion that the default one I used
and as you can see it took some layers
and side of layers activation functions
are so on so this really just like a
noodle Network it just like a fancy name
in the same way we have like Alex net
and Google net and so on then we have
mobile net and then there's only one
Orca like Inception they really have
like fastenings is this one yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's called more than that
I'm mobile because it's quite weak in
compared to the other which are like
Inception version to Inception version 3
so they have like more harsh name we
could say and this is just like more
than that no but really a lot like if
you actually read the specification in
the papers you can see there big
difference
like others they're like big bigger and
bigger net word that you sly more rigid
hyperparameters and so on and this one
is more like more relaxed we could say
then we can all remember today that he
was still here not yet the millionaire
because he hasn't made the Pokedex yet
but I'm sure one this was amazing thank
you
[Applause]